[Music]
for
our
son friend
[Music]
h
[Applause]
first of all I want to thank you every
single one of you for coming out and
supporting this effort what the
opposition is hoping for is that you
will give
up never
forget um and and so I I'm stunned and
thrilled that you all came out this
evening we had no you know uh tress I
mean we had PR nobody open them that's
true that's Hall um and understand the
objective of this evening and of this
film uh The Ground Zero mosque story was
ignored by the media for five months and
when the media found that they couldn't
ignore anymore because tens of thousands
of people came to our rallies they
started to shape the narrative and this
is what this movie is the movie is a
tool for you because each one of you is
your own little media organization and I
cannot overstate this enough I know this
is not a passive viewing audience I know
who you are now I know you work I know
you don't have a lot of time but you
must email the stories you must email
the events it's how the ground zero mask
became the number one national news
story and the number one international
news story we have British TV in in in
the in the room uh because of you and
what is interesting is when the media
decided to cover it you get to see the
perversion how they twist it and how
they demonized Freedom loving Americans
anybody that opposed The Masque so what
I hope you'll do is because we're still
tweaking this film we're making it and
going going and making it um when we do
press the CDs the DVDs that you get one
and you have in your living room invite
your friends send the link this is it's
all it may seem ha but you don't know
when you throw that little Pebble in the
water you don't see the reverberations
of what you do this is how we're going
to win the fight not just this fight but
there are many many fights taking place
uh The Ground Zero mosque for me
obviously is very iconic of the bigger
struggle and we cannot give up because
remember one thing we have been very
successful oh yeah oh yes Imam rouf and
Daisy Khan have been moved Now
understand it's like a it's like a show
they've been moved they're off stage now
they're at stage two
Andy the second guy again because we
revealed on my blog we revealed Abdullah
adamy was uh you know uh a dummy I
pronounced
correctly Abdullah adami you know he uh
was uh very close to a unindicted
co-conspirator in the World Trade Center
bombies in
1993 um SJ wahaj who testified in the
trial that conviction of the blind Shake
in the World Trade Center bombings so he
really became toxic and then of course
the comments about the gay community but
what I'm saying is that we will not stop
we will not stop they have not raised
the money because they know we're going
to look at the money we're going to look
at the money we're going to find out
where the
from have you do not stop learn from the
enemy never give up never give up give
up never give up because I'm telling you
they're rattled if you look at the
correspondence between Imam rou and uh
the mayor's office Mayor blomberg's
office if you look at Mayor Bloomberg's
correspondance between the two you will
see they were very very um uptight and
nervous about how to handle the
opposition and so City Hall wrote the
letters for them I mean that's how
extraordinary the collusion was
but that's how intimidated they were by
us and so I asked that we're going to do
a Q&A we have the 911 family members in
the front row afterwards um I ask that
you not stop I am thrilled I cannot tell
you to see a full house here it's just
it's just warming the cockle of cockles
of this Jewish mother's heart I can't
even get to tell you because that was
what I was nervous about but you you
don't stop and I I have to say God bless
you for everything that you do bless I
want to thank God bless you
and I want I want to thank pela Hall who
is my right hand who works like she's
[Music]
amazing and David Miles David Miles who
filmed our our rallies on June the 6th
on September the 11th these are people
that work like dogs and nobody says
anything and so thank you very much
and Floyd we have to thank Floyd yeah he
he protects my my sorry butt okay and
I'd like just Robert cell phones on
vibrate please oh yes I'll have to do
that too um and I'd like to introduce my
colleague my partner in crime the
dynamic the other half of the dynamic
duo Robert
spener everybody up we're g to pledge
allegiance to the flag all
right it's on house jack
IED Al to the flag of the United States
of America and to the Republic for it
stands one nation God indivisible with
liy and justice for
[Applause]
here thank you all again for coming when
the Muslim armies rolled into Jerusalem
in
636 one of the first things they did was
begin construction of the alaka mosque
and where did they put it on the Temple
Mount and they put it on the Temple
Mount and they built the Dome of the
Rock later on the Temple Mount also in
order to show the superiority of Islam
over Judaism and the Victory of Islam
over Judaism on May 29th
1453 the city of Constantinople was
conquered by the Muslims and the first
thing the sultan mehmed the Conqueror
did was go into the church that
Cathedral of the Agia Sophia in
Constantinople which was at that time
the grandest church in the whole
Christian world dwarfing the Vatican
everything else and he went in there
with an Imam and the Imam went up into
the pulpit and said the shahada and
proclaimed that it was a mosque to Mark
the Triumph of the Muslims and the
Victory of the Muslims over the
Christian Empire and the superiority of
Islam over
Christianity on September 11th 2001 they
took down the Twin Towers now they are
trying to mark their
Victory and we cannot let them do it we
are on to them we know what they're
doing we know how they're lying and
we're never going to give
up
[Applause]
so and so this film details the
controversy but this film is just
chapter one and it's up to all of you
and all of us here and everybody who
loves freedom to write the next chapter
the victory of the freedom fre Freedom
loving people and the United States of
America over these Islamic supremacists
[Music]